[Music]
the World Health Organization has
announced that these sexually
transmitted disease gonorrhea is now
growing resistant to drugs and will soon
be untreatable imagine that yeah that's
right ladies and I'm an untreatable
gonorrhea
[Applause]
what the hell is that
Howard why did you just cut to that guy
in the audience sorry sorry Conan my bad
just just a freak accident freak
accident
sir I'm really sorry that that happened
that was completely screwed up I am very
sorry I apologize that was anyway as I
was saying the World Health Organization
has announced that we could soon have
untreatable gonorrhea
[Applause]
what the hell
Allen that could not possibly been an
accident that time sorry again
sorry just some minor technical
difficulties up here in the booth I'm
really sorry cog technical difficulties
you had an untreatable gonorrhea graphic
and voiceover loaded up
[Applause]
I'm really sorry what are you doing I'm
sorry Kevin I thought you were calling
for the graphic and voiceover again my
bad technical issues all right well okay
just stop it and sir I really do
apologize
okay I'm sorry and we'll get that
straightened out anyway the World Health
Organization announced that untreatable
gonorrhea now so everybody we're the
untreatable gonorrhea
dancers to welcome a special guest this
guy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
how is that sorry I hit the wrong button
guys just get out of here please go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you can take that off that's okay
so sorry sir you know and I promise you
I'm not even going to go ahead and tell
that joke about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]